let's jump into this first story from
motherboard
vice.com anarchist collective shares
instructions to make diy abortion pills
diy medicine collectives are preparing
for the horrifying prospect that roe v
wade will be overturned
and this image
i guess that's misoprostol i suppose
they're saying the supreme court poised
to overturn the constitutional rights to
abortion constitutional right an
anarchist collective that makes diy
medicine has released detailed
instructions for making abortion pills
the group has previously released
instructions for making diy epipen and
for making
uh what is that daraprim
daraprim
i don't know you're the fancy doctor
lydia was that down yeah i can't uh dark
yeah i've not seen that word the pill
that made farmer bro martin shkreli
famous
we talked about this a bit on the show
that like i think was thomas with thomas
massey that
horse and no no sheep epinephrine
is like 30 bucks for 50 doses
and it's like the same dosage a person
gets and it's like oh but you can't take
sheet medicine and i think thomas is
saying no it's literally the same thing
yeah that's like an epipen is 500 bucks
the insurance agencies are colluding
with the pharmaceutical companies to
spike the prices you pay your insurance
they pay the claim for you they raise
your insurance and then you get this
overpriced medicine well i don't know
about all that but what i do know is in
the article it says in the video law
firm explains that besides being used to
medically induce abortions misoprostol
is also used to treat ulcers in horses
this makes misoprostol powder relatively
easy to acquire from veterinary
veterinary sources this is reminiscent
of vermectin which is used to control
parasites and horses but also became a
favored but an effective covert
treatment among conspiracy theorists
ivermectin's uses use in horses made it
easier for humans to get without a
prescription
this is amazing lawfur explains in the
video how to dose misoprostol and how to
press in
it into pills using a scale corn syrup
powdered sugar a spray bottle and a
pollen press they explain that a three
dose regimen of misoprostol is 85
effective inducing in inducing abortion
if taken with mythopristone another
abortion pill that raise it that rate
raises oh if taken with uh mifa preston
does that he said that the rate rises to
95 effectiveness through uh though ram
if a preston is harder to source so what
they're actually saying in this
is that people who are outraged over the
potential overturning of roe v wade have
told people to go to the vet to buy
horse medicine so they can have
abortions look if the worst case
scenario about the ivermectin horse
paste thing was that it didn't do
anything it didn't do anything there
were some stores where people getting
sick they would eat like a tube of horse
paste and you can't do that
but this actually hurts you this is like
a poison and another advocating for this
my friends well they've been advocating
for poisoning babies for quite a long
time look look
i know i say this quite a bit
when people go to you and they say
you know you're lying your sources of
news aren't real or whatever
people say to us how do i convince my
parents or my friends and my family that
you know the the news is fake
here
this
after everything they said about horse
medicine and joe rogan and this and the
smears they're now advocating for it
what more do you need to be like well
now they're saying take horse pills
i mean look if at this point someone can
see that and they think to themselves
well this one's okay it's like okay you
have no interest in being honest and
actually talking about what you believe
you have no principles
whatever man there's a couple layers to
this one is firstly it's not horse
medicine it's medicine that they put
into a horse paste to feed the horses
it's so same with ivermectin it's a
medicine that was used in a horse
environment sometimes but it's not horse
medicine it's just medicine
secondly i talked about this last night
people are going to be inducing
miscarriages now
this is that's the problem with making
it illegal is people are going to keep
doing it and they're going to find
probably more dangerous and violent ways
to do it that's my concern anyway and
then this pops up yeah i mean i strongly
believe that fewer people are going to
do it no law is perfect you're never
going to prevent 100 of any crime you
try to deter people from committing but
ultimately making it illegal to have
abortions does prevent them and if it
didn't the left wouldn't really be upset
about all this you know to follow up on
that point i thought the same thing
about murder because last night i was
thinking about our conversation and like
you know if murder was legal there would
be a lot more murder yeah so there is
something to making things illegal and
preventing the
the uh the proliferation of the activity
yeah i just don't like top down i don't
like saying now you now it's illegal so
no one can do it anymore like now it's
illegal to have guns so no one can 3d
print them anymore yeah right people are
going to still 3d print guns and you're
just going to create a criminal class no
i agree especially with gun control it's
complicated because people are finding
more and more ways to create them and
get them but ultimately part of the
reason why we oppose gun control is
because we know it would be harder to
get a firearm and fewer of us would be
able to if it were implemented so there
is some effectiveness i mean gun control
certainly is not effective at lowering
gun crime uh or preventing homicide or
anything like that but it is
in some cases very effective at getting
guns out of the hands of law-abiding
citizens because the law can be
effective what do you think elena about
all this
i mean i'm i'm really conflicted on all
of the abortion stuff i mean i
i'm not entirely compelled by the
pro-life arguments but i also
i recognize that a lot of a lot of the
pro-choice or i guess pro-abortion
arguments are
just coming from very seemingly unwell
people and that there's just there's
something
anti-woman
anti-human something that just
hates motherhood about it and it just it
really sceees me out so i'm just
watching all this stuff and and just
thinking like
how can we have a conversation about
this that isn't completely split between
these two i don't i don't so uh
the argument for over the past week or
so with elon musk is that the left you
post this meme showing the left moving
further and further left
and the right's kind of staying where it
is in the center then becomes right wing
because the left moves so far left and
the left keeps saying oh no that's not
true that's not happening
my response is
when i was a kid the right wanted to ban
abortion
as i grew up the left was saying safe
legal and rare a compromise no late term
abortions most people in this country
even today disagree with abortions after
the first trimester that means second
trimester and third no abortions
i think the new york times reported this
that roe v wade actually pro
stops certain restrictions on abortion
in the second trimester which creates
this paradox but
we're gonna we get to get to that in a
second so the right today still wants to
ban abortion but now the left wants all
restrictions removed which is a huge
leap from where it was when i was
younger safe legal and rare meaning
in the first trimester if there are
certain issues so the issues that get
brought up frequently are ectopic
pregnancies which i suppose the the
argument sheamus you and matt walsh
brought up is that you don't consider an
abortion
pregnancy what does that mean it's the
principle of double effect so basically
there are certain medical procedures you
might have to perform on a sick woman
who happens to be pregnant that could
result in the death of the unborn child
and you perform that surgery to save her
life and if the unborn child dies that's
unfortunate but your intention is not to
go in there and kill the child it's an
unintended side effect of the operation
so that isn't considered an abortion i
think that's including by certain
pro-choice organizations by the way many
of them won't call it an abortion i know
webmd doesn't call out an abortion i
believe planned parenthood does not call
it so this has been superseded this is
the argument that's that's often made
from the left because i don't think
they're having conversations with
conservatives because i think talking to
matt walsh was particularly enlightening
he said
if you have to turn he effectively said
you can terminate a pregnancy it doesn't
mean you have to kill the baby meaning
at certain points if you can save the
baby's life why wouldn't you do it
so it's like
there's an interesting question i think
for most pro-abortion people
we should ask if a woman is pregnant in
the second or third trimester and the
baby can safely be removed ending the
pregnancy but the baby can also be saved
should that be mandated
yeah i think i mean i think they would
say no it's interesting you mentioned
that the left has become more extreme on
this issue and i completely agree but on
the other hand i think they've really
just become more consistent to their
their base principle here on the right
the argument was that this is a human
life and so it has to be protected from
conception until natural death and on
the side of the left it was basically
the argument that like either we don't
know if this is a human life or it
alt-right isn't a human life and in that
case it doesn't make sense to restrict
it at all so we were we were talking a
little bit before the show and helena
was saying you were saying that you know
you're not you don't have a really
strong position on this
i don't i don't i'm sorry no you don't
have to because i actually i i kind of
agree with you
there's uh i don't have i don't have a
particularly strong position on this
because it's it's almost an impossible
moral question and i keep looking to the
left for moral arguments which they
don't have they they and so i'm like
okay
you know i've heard the argument me tim
i've heard the arguments from the right
and they're static like here's the
argument life begins at conception
life you know life has rights the
government has to protect the rights of
the living you have two people and i'm
like there's a really interesting
ethical conundrum in here when we're
talking about the rights of two people
sharing one body in one bloodstream and
then look to the left and they say
things like
life doesn't begin until first breath
that's that's a quote from the bible i
think well no no it's not from the bible
there are certain people who have tried
to argue that because
adam takes or god breathes life into
adam in the old testament that that
means that scripture is saying life does
not begin until the first breath but
that's an unbelievable reach and
the prohibition on abortion is one of
the earliest christian teachings i mean
it states all the way back to the first
century so it's just not true either way
i'm not entirely sure um
what the left does want
so my position and my family has always
been like what we talk about all the
time is it's safe legal and rare that's
the famous saying even tulsi gabbard was
saying it and it's like
there should be restrictions
and so my position is not particularly
strong i really don't know
and i don't understand why so many
people are screaming the top of their
lungs about this because abortion wasn't
even banned it's just going to a
state-level thing so it's like okay i
don't know petition your state vote for
your local reps or if you're the
majority of democrats and you live in a
blue state you have nothing to worry
about i think some of it is just sort of
your classic typical histrionic leftist
behavior every time something goes wrong
for them in politics they end up
throwing a tantrum and will even burn
down cities attack people commit acts of
violence another part of it is i think
there are some number of people whose
consciences are genuinely bothered
because either they've had an abortion
or they've helped someone participate
you know they've participated in helping
someone procure an abortion and they
haven't really reconciled with the
wrongness of that and so anything that
reminds them that some people don't
approve of that behavior really sends
them off the edge thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time